all right we now know when the games
will be played in 2020 we can take a
look at the revenge games and revenge is
something that can be interpreted very
broadly chris sims players versus
players teams versus teams players
versus teams coaches versus coaches
whatever the case may be trivia question
goes to you if you get it right you get
the first pick odell beckham jr's 1450
receiving yards in 2015 are the second
highest season total
in giants history and of course beckham
gets his first crack at the giants by
way of revenge this year who holds the
giants franchise record single season
with
1536 receiving yards
wow gosh i'm not going to say popsicle
barrels
do you want to hear no no i don't i'm
not even going to take the i'm going to
say it's i'm going to go with steve
smith
and victor cruz
oh
2011. victor cruz i know they won the
super bowl
uh
uh look i this one sometimes you got to
pluck the low-hanging fruit jimmy
garoppolo 49ers quarterback taking on
the team that traded him away the team
that could have made him
the new quarterback could have gone with
him instead of tom brady could have
traded tom brady to the 49ers back in
2017 and trusted the younger option
instead they cast jimmy garoppolo off
into the wilderness with the san
francisco 49ers he's been paid
handsomely probably more than he would
have been paid by the patriots but don't
let that get in the way of a good story
either garoppolo facing the team that
traded him away 49ers patriots best
revenge game of the year chris
well it's definitely good there's no
doubt about that i mean there's going to
be something a little extra added into
that let alone like you know i think
jared stidham's going to want to show
people that hey he's the better
replacement to brady than jimmy
garoppolo was but uh i'm with you you
know that's there's gonna be there's a
little history between these two
football teams and i think yes you know
with jimmy garoppolo going to new
england week seven uh he'll certainly
want to stick it to the team for trading
them away and and show that he started a
new winning era there with the san
francisco 49ers so good pick by you uh
i'm gonna go more of the
the
the team thing here first off and i mean
what better revenge you know for a saint
to
get revenge on christmas day right i
mean saints can't lose on christmas day
and they play the minnesota vikings yes
their chance to get revenge of
gosh two out of the last three years you
know really losing to the minnesota
vikings and heartbreaking fashion in the
playoffs i mean we know the you know the
the minneapolis miracle but last year
certainly a controversial game with the
was it past interference was it not with
uh you know uh who was the tight end in
the end zone there i'm blanking
kyle rudolph sorry you know what whether
that was pi or not and the saints at
crashing their season to an end uh to me
that's one i look at that revenge game
there and uh week
what is that week 16 christmas day
should be pretty damn good
yeah i mean the only flaw in your
argument is that they already got
revenge for the minneapolis miracle
because they went back to minnesota and
beat them the following regular season
on a sunday night so
it's not full revenge for all past
transgressions i already got partial
revenge but at least as it relates to
last year's playoffs it's in the same
place just like the 2018 game was in the
same place as the postseason game this
one's in the same place i wish it was
earlier in the year it would have a
little more of that revenge field
earlier in the year in the same place
getting together again but i look it was
on my list i can't i can't lie about
that all right uh next one for me comes
week six october 18 when the cleveland
browns travel to pittsburgh to take on
the steelers and miles garrett is in
uniform and miles garrett gets a proper
welcome by the folks in pittsburgh who
didn't get to see him last year because
he was suspended for six games for cold
cocking mason rudolph in the head with
his own helmet and i don't know who the
revenge is it's just like all of
pittsburgh versus miles garrett because
mason rudolph if he's playing in that
game
the steelers are gonna have bigger
things to worry about than getting
revenge on miles garrett and i am not
advising or suggesting or inciting any
type of of violence above and beyond
what the rules call for i'm talking
about the whole experience for miles
garrett is going to be unpleasant from
the moment he walks out of the tunnel
and from the moment he faces some of
those steelers players who are still
salty about what happened last year
it's early enough in the year that i
think it's still relevant miles garrett
versus the entire city of pittsburgh and
the entire steelers organization that
one should be fun to watch chris yes it
definitely should be uh there's no doubt
i mean that's gonna be
the refs had better be on their p's and
q's that day because it's there's gonna
be intensity in the air on the field in
the crowd everything about it uh people
people in pittsburgh are gonna want
miles garrett to pay i mean i understand
that certainly uh but miles garrett one
of the best defensive players in all of
football
certainly uh certainly i'll have his say
in the matter at some point all right
i'm gonna go here much worse just hang
on a second think how much worse it
would have been for miles garrett if he
had done what he did to ben
roethlisberger like i'm not saying they
don't care about mason rudolph in
pittsburgh but they don't care about
mason rudolph in pittsburgh what if they
had done that to ben can you imagine how
much worse it would have been how much
bigger of a deal it would be it's still
a huge deal anyway i just had to
interject that goal no it would have
been a way bigger deal though i mean
when you start getting into the
franchise quarterback conversation they
get treated differently i mean we know
that and yeah big ben is one of those
quarterbacks that's put into that
category of like you know historic
figure in the history of the nfl and it
would have been a way bigger story of
that was big ben getting bashed over the
head uh as compared to mason rudolph i'm
with you there all right i mean i'm
going with this more of like a statement
a little bit but like still revenge
maybe not quite to the way we want it
right but the ravens chiefs week three
to me is a big one where i look at first
off the ravens are trying to be the
kings of the afc all right they've lost
to the chiefs the last two years they
certainly don't seem like they match up
well with them i just look at that as
someone's like a semi-revenge semi if
you want to prove to everybody
in the afc world or the nfl world that's
watching you're going to need to beat
the kansas city chiefs at some point and
you know the ravens are flirting with
that you know like you've said many
times man are they going to win a
playoff game with lamar jackson you know
the kansas city chiefs are 2-0 against
them mahomes has lamar jackson's number
all of those things i just look at that
as a big game for the ravens to
basically say
okay we can be we can beat the kansas
city chiefs we can win a playoff tight
atmosphere type of football game and
answer some of those questions we have
about them right now you know uh so
there's nothing personal there but i
think they're two of the best teams in
the afc clearly and i just think there's
a lot a lot on the line in that in that
battle
i thought you were gonna go titans
ravens that's a true revenge game right
titans at ravens they play that's not my
pick but they play in november it's a
one o'clock eastern game i'm surprised
yeah it's a week week 11 4 25 game i
guess it could get flexed into 425 and
maybe the schedule makers don't expect
the titans to be very good this year all
right the next one for me is week nine
sunday night football on nbc
saints and buccaneers now you say how
was that revenge well they played one so
so the week nine game it's a little in
season revenge the week nine games
whoever loses ah it works but you like
it you you you refuse to admit it you
refuse to concede the point but deep
down you know there's appeal to this
whoever loses the week one game is the
guy whether it's drew brees or tom brady
who gets his shot at revenge week nine
prime time on nbc it's a revenge game
for which there's no need for revenge
before the season starts but there will
be after the first weekend take that
boom roasted
wow i mean that is just you talk about
like moving the rules of the draft and
all that all revenge game
it's a revenge game who's getting
revenge on who who's getting revenge
this is in week one
we don't know yet so we win
for the draft everybody
we will
nicole back there in the room just put
whoever okay for his second his third
round pick whoever all right that's all
he deserves on there he doesn't deserve
a team with that bull crap all right how
could i not go to week nine as well
thank you thank you for only saying bull
crap by the way thank you i'm on a roll
hey week nine as well i mean come on the
green bay packers if you want me to take
you seriously as a super bowl contender
you're gonna have to show me you can put
up a competitive football game in san
francisco i mean they got railroad
railroaded both times there last year
that if that doesn't speak revenge to
one getting your butt kicked on monday
night football and then two getting your
butt kicked in the nfc championship game
uh that will be one of the ultimate
revenge games of the year to see where
green bay has come and can they really
dethrone or challenge the top teams in
the nfc like the san francisco 49ers on
the road and put up a better showing
than what we saw last year hey and in
the event that the pandemic requires the
49ers to not play their games in
california that's good news for the
packers because every time they went to
california last year they got stomped
they should not want to play any games
in california if they can avoid it and
the pandemic may require it and on that
note we're going to take a break
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports